[Music]
justice being in a Superbowl commercial
is a pretty big deal that's why
companies are shelling out about five
point six million dollars for a
30-second commercial spot during this
year's broadcast for movie stars like
Keanu Reeves to musicians like Lil nas
x2 / Bowl commercials can be an
incredibly lucrative way to get some
promotion during one of America's
biggest sporting events
let's have a look at 10 of the most
star-studded commercials that will be
broadcasted during this year's big game
and be sure to stick around to the end
because some of our favorite animated
stars are getting in on the action
Old Town Road was one of the biggest hit
songs of 2019 so of course companies
were in a rush to see if any of them
could secure lil nods X and his song for
their Super Bowl commercial well it
looks like Doritos came out on top and
they also managed to secure Sam Elliott
an actor known for his cowboy persona to
join little nas ex in the commercial the
ad features Sam Elliott doing the spoken
rendition of old town road for confused
bartender before little nas ex rides in
on his horse the full trailer leads up
to a showdown between lil nas and Elliot
but it's not a typical Western showdown
that's right
it's a dance battle Sam Elliot admitted
that dancing in the commercial was the
hardest part of filming even though it's
actually the first commercial he's
appeared in in over 40 years
naturally little nas came out of the
dance battle of winner and when he asked
if anyone else wants a piece of him
Billy Ray Cyrus makes a quick cameo to
say that he ain't dancing it's a fitting
opportunity for Doritos to use the
clueless Cowboys they know to promote
their cool ranch flavored chips Ellen
DeGeneres for Amazon Amazon always
secures some pretty big celebs for their
Superbowl commercials last year one of
their ads featured cardi B to promote
Alexa this year the company went with
Ellen DeGeneres and Porsche to Rosie the
ad shows them fighting over the
temperature they should keep their homes
at with Alexa caught between them as
they repeatedly asked her to change it
then after asking what do you think
people did before Alexa we get a little
blast from the past in the form of
people trying to change the temperature
listen to music and read the news before
Alexa was there to help them out all of
the helpers have a similar name to Alexa
like Alec seen Alyssa and Alicia but
they can't get the job done quite as
good as Amazon's Alexa Ellen drives this
point home by asking Alexa to order her
wine and using echo audio to ask Alexa
to play music in her car this is
actually Amazon's fifth consecutive
Super Bowl ad promoting the device and
considering that users spent about two
billion dollars per year on Alexa skills
we're sure to see many more Super Bowl
commercials starring our favorite
voice-activated Helper ed sheeran for
Heinz ed Sheeran loves ketchup so much
that he actually got the Heinz ketchup
bought a logo tattooed on his body
yep that's commitment so really it's no
surprise that he decided to team up with
Heinz for a Super Bowl ad featuring his
favorite condiment the commercials shows
them at a fancy restaurant smear and
ketchup all over his food as people look
on in horror
hey there's no such thing as being too
good for ketchup right ed Sheeran
definitely think so in fact Sheeran
teamed up with the ketchup company
before to release a limited series of
150 bottles of Heinz decorated and
artwork inspired by Sheeran's other
tattoos you then auctioned off these
bottles for charity with sales reaching
up to eighteen hundred dollars that's
some pretty fancy ketchup that leads us
to the question would you smear your
plate with ketchup at even the most
fancy restaurant
ed Sheeran sure hope so ed Sheeran isn't
the only celebrity with some not so
fancy taste
John Legend and his wife Chrissy Teigen
seem to want to take a step back from
traditional luxury in their Superbowl ad
the couple teamed up to promote Genesis
Hyundais luxury car brand the car
company is using the Super Bowl to
launch its first SUV the GV 80 and a new
brand campaign called young luxury so
who better to promote the brand than one
of the hottest young couples who also
happens to be huge social media stars
the ad shows legend and Tegan throwing a
goodbye party to old luxury the couple
rejects a pool ice sculpture in favor of
curse crackers and topples over an
expensive oyster bar but don't worry
Tegan still eats the oysters and when
legend messes up the big car reveal
Tegan gives them a bit of a hard time
about it something she is known for
doing on Twitter and then refers to his
title as sexiest man alive before being
allowed in the car the cool
modern couple drives off in their cool
modern car ditching out on their own
party in favor of some young luxury
comfort but stay tuned because this
isn't the only star-studded Hyundai
commercial on our list Squarespace has
been beefing up its ad game over the
years with a little help from Keanu
Reeves the actor known for some pretty
great action films brought his skills to
a commercial for the site in 2018 by
riding a motorcycle while standing as he
gives himself a little pep talk but of
course he's wearing a helmet because
safety first the ad encourages people to
use the website building site to express
who they are Keano chants make it happen
as he finally sits on his bike and rides
off presumably enlightened by the open
air and ready to get his website going
but this year's commercials will feature
more than just Keano
Winona Ryder also appears in an ad for
the company in it she's laying on the
side of a road in the snow as she
contemplates what she wants her website
to look like be sure to keep a lookout
for squarespace's other star-studded
advertisements during this year's game
Bryan Cranston from Mountain Dew Bryan
Cranston is an incredible actor so it's
no surprise that the commercial he's
appearing in this year is a quick remake
of one of the Shining's most iconic
scenes the actor takes on the role of
writer gone mad Jack Torrance except
this time he's going mad for soda
Cranston appears with Tracee Ellis Ross
playing his terrified wife he breaks
down the door with an axe and sticks his
head through the hole asking Tracy if
she'd like a little Mountain Dew I am
thirsty she accepts the refreshment
happily and then the commercial ends
with a flood of Mountain Dew pouring out
on the elevator and the slogan as good
as the original is a nice little touch
for the mini remake so how is it
possible to make an ad for soda so scary
I guess the secret is Bryan Cranston's
acting chops Tracee Ellis Ross is iconic
scream and a whole bunch of Mountain Dew
Bill Nye for SodaStream one of our
favorite scientists is going to be
featured during the Super Bowl in a
promotion for SodaStream the teaser
promises us that something big is
bubbling as Bill Nye realizes that
humans living on Mars isn't so far off
after all the Bill Nye isn't just
promoting the company for a check nye
actually uses the SodaStream machines at
his own home and in his office and while
he doesn't think using
a stream is the answer to climate change
he does think that drinking carbonated
water in a reusable bottle to make a
difference
SodaStream claims that over 1.6 billion
bottles of water have avoided becoming
waste because of their system so at
least Bill Nye is appearing in something
he supports and he's also admitted that
it's just really cool being in a Super
Bowl ad
we can't help but agree I made me wrong
about that MC Hammer for Cheetos it is
short but hilarious teaser for their
2020 Super Bowl ad Cheetos and MC Hammer
Teemo for a commercial that can't be
touched while humming his hit song you
can't touch this MC Hammer goes to play
his piano and realizes that he has a
problem we've all dealt with before he
has cheeto fingers he sighs looks at his
sticky orange fingers and the white
piano keys and says that he just can't
touch this the ad also takes place in
1989 when he conceived the song and he
looks at the camera after realizing the
cheetos have just given him his greatest
hit the longer version of the commercial
features MC Hammer popping out of places
as a man goes about his day unable to
help anyone around him because he's busy
eating Cheetos and his hands are dirty
then MC Hammer shuffles away with a bag
of Cheetos popcorn major props at
scheels for using such an iconic song to
demonstrate how their product doesn't
just taste good it can also get us out
of our responsibilities maybe next time
were called into the office we should
claim a Cheetos day instead of a sick
day Chris Evans for Honda here's the
second Hyundai commercial on our list
and it features even more stars in the
first one but with a slightly less
luxurious car Chris Evans John Krasinski
Rachel Dratch and David Big Papi Ortiz
all appear in the commercial for the
company's smart park system but each
celebrity really hams up the ad with
their Boston accents as they go on about
the places they can now easily pop their
car using the feature John drives up and
astonishes Chris and Rachel by hopping
out of his blue sedan and pressing a
button so it'll park itself the car even
gets referred to as a ghost car by a
passerby who can't believe it has no
driver
Hyundai makes sure to let us know that
parking is bet out with them and the ad
is a cool opportunity for some accent
ASMR from some of our favorite stars and
fun fact Rachel Chris and John are all
from Massachusetts so we're sure they
relish the opportunity to get back to
their
Rick and Morty four Pringles celebrity
icons don't have to be real people right
well if you disagree tell that to Rick
Morty and summer who appear in a fully
animated ad for Pringle the ad brings
the usual Rick and Morty Flair to the
super bowl featuring morty becoming
obsessed with Pringles and all their
flavor combinations like jalapeno and
pizza as Rick realizes that there's now
a bunch of robot Morty's taking over
their house chanting about their
absolute favorite chips the commercial
also gets pretty meta
while watching a Pringles ad on TV
summer asks how much Rick thinks the
people appearing in a Pringles ad make
Rick says it's probably barely anything
so did Rick and Morty get paid dust
promote the snack who knows but they
probably regret it now that they're
stuck in a Pringles commercial for all
of eternity but hey at least we got a
self-aware Superbowl commercial out of
it so what's your favorite commercial on
our list and are there any others you're
looking forward to seeing during the
game let us know what you think in the
comments thanks for watching don't
forget to hit that like button and
subscribe for more great content
[Music]
you